it's kind of comfortable at times to to
do stuff that you feel you intrinsically
know
what I mean is know at least in terms of
body language
dialogue
no dialogue Good Fellas it was very
special I was looking for something that
I could find another way of dealing with
genre and I think really that's what
started to get me really interested in
the characters in the world that it
depicted in a genre that I've kind of
felt most comfortable with over the
years that world is something that deals
with very basic conflicts basic dilemmas
moral dilemmas that I grew up with and
so I feel comfortable with it there's
something about De Niro who understands
the humanity of all kinds of people and
could really
Express that